in this sport you have to be very hungry
or other way like someone gonna come and
hurt you when you have family kids when
you have all life
ahead you know it's like this is this is
not easy like like I remember I grew up
in a very small village with very poor
life you know and my father he bring us
from Village
he sell his house he sell our house and
he bring me my brother my cousins like
it was like almost 15 people from
Village to Capital City
he rent very big house
and we all was living together we was
eat together it was like going School
come back training come back just father
try to invest everything what they have
time energy money he invest us he
investors in from this house he's become
sixth world champion UFC champion you
know a lot of Champions and very good
people because father invest everything
what they have he give us good education
and you know I was like he gave us good
opportunity to learn in good schools
University you know he invests
everything what they have all his life
he was doing he was investing people and
you know this is very big motivation for
me even now when I'm finished
like
right now I'm trying to invest people
invest my close people because this is
best investment you know I can live I
can live for myself I can do whatever I
want in the world I can buy any house in
the world you know but this is don't
give me good energy this is like this is
not who I am this is not what my father
teach me you know and I'm very happy
about this because like I remember like
10 years ago my mind was completely
different oh I'm gonna become Champion
I'm gonna become rich I'm gonna buy
everything but every like everything
what happened last two years
this has changed my mind and the change
the way I was thinking you know it was
3rd July 2020 two years ago almost two
years ago after a couple years it's
gonna be two years father is not with me
you know it's very hard time right now
staying here and talk about him you know
it's very emotional for me I have very
good amateur career I become two-time
Russian Champion two-time world champion
in combat [__]
I was competed everywhere I remember
when I grew up father father make me
compete like Freestyle Wrestling great
karuman pancreation grappling immature
MMA combat [__] even hit he make me
like wrestle with the Beards you know
this is like this is this is how he
teach me this is how he tried to teach
me because he always tell me
when you're gonna go to big arena you
can handle any any pressure you can
handle any pressure when you go to the
big arena bath right now you have to
work hard
and I remember when I asked him when I
was young I was very young maybe like
six seven years old I remember it was
like listen for all my life I ask him
money he said okay I'm gonna give you
money but you have to deserve this
you think I'm gonna give you everything
what you want no you have to deserve
this
you know it's like it was very big
lesson like any people anybody in the
world who who just come out from poor
life and he becomes success let's say
like not only in sport like
and like
anywhere he becomes success he's gonna
be humble because he he what you see
like other life and see his this life
like they can he can compare you know he
watch he can like if he's not crazy of
course like a lot of people
underestimate one things when they
become famous when they become rich when
they become success they all
beginning talk about oh you know this is
because of my mindset this is because of
I work hard this is because my business
mind is very smart you know I'm very
strong guy I can't handle anything in
the world you know that's why I become
like very success you know for example
they all talk talk about this but what
about other millions and millions people
around the world
who work so hard but they don't have
this position what I have it's been this
is test from Allah this is test from God
he give you this he want to taste you
how you're gonna handle this you know
and don't make this mistake guys
everything come from God you know you
guys have to show by yourself by
yourself what is this like be example
for your kids this is very important a
lot of a lot of parents like a lot of
others they just told their sons okay
don't go there don't do this do this be
on this way no you have to be on good
way and your son gonna follow you or
your daughter gonna follow you your kids
gonna follow you just be example for
your kids you know this is my advice for
All fathers and mothers
and it was very difficult time for me
you know I remember when I was talking
with my father maybe it's like maybe I'm
gonna maybe maybe I should like retire
it what do you think like because I'm
tired again again surgery Soldier you
know and he said like if you want to
give up you can give up this is your
choice you can do whatever you want but
how you gonna give up like so many years
we were working together like and you
like only 26 years old I remember myself
when I was 26 and 33 this is too
different
you know like my prime time it was 32-33
your time's Gonna Come
but you cannot give up you know and this
give me like crazy motivation I never
gave up I never even remember I give up
on training tab or like an amateur
career professional career in the gym
never in my life a lot of people ask me
you proud of something I'm very proud of
I never give up
I don't want to be example and I never
try to be like to be example for people
you know I have small community around
me like my kids my family my brothers I
try to give them example and of course
because I'm famous I cannot do nothing
with this you know but
it's not easy you know I already improve
myself I'm working like everywhere like
grappling
striking wrestling conditioning
um
like if you guys watch my every fight
every fight I improve you know if you
want to be Champion if you have if you
want defend your title you have to
become high with the MMA because MMA
every day like grow up like go high high
because Lara tough young hungry guys
coming and you have to be ready for
everybody and that's why I keep going
you have to learn every day something
every day you have to learn and like
even if you talk about grappling I don't
show everything what I can do and
I'm working on my hip position I'm
working on my Mount position you know
it's like take break like my job is
defend my title you know number one job
it's my defend my title if I won't
defend my title I have to spend five
hours every day in the gym you know
that's why everything is together if you
lose something everything goes down
that's why I try to control everything
because I know the history of MMA I know
uh this history of Champions a lot of
Champions when they become champion and
a lot of guys like uh when they win they
a little bit change
like Ronda Rousey like this is not about
the bad people this is about like
sometimes you can control everything
like if before when you become Champion
if you train every day two time when you
become Champions sometimes you train one
time on one day
like you can train maybe a little bit
running and you think you're training
but when you go to the cage you you know
need for running you need spotting you
need grappling you're not wrestling you
need hard work like before when you
become Champion you work because you're
hungry you need this and you have big
motivation then you become Champion
you're a little bit lose your motivation
but you and you forget about other guys
yeah a lot of guys coming like
training so hard very hungry and you
have to understand this I know this I
know this way I know this stuff and
that's why I keep training
keep working thank you
[Applause]